but what was it like like a movie like
gladiator again intense it was
incredible my my first day i is
well i get to malta and
i walk on a
huge
huge set it's like rome they've built
[ __ ] rome and there's hyenas and
giraffes and tigers and lions and all
coming parading down the streets huge
big cranes swooping in and okay tommy we
need you
and remember i didn't have any training
i did some theater i did
some theater there was a thing yeah it's
training
which was great for the acting thing but
as far as filming went right i just i
just sat there and watched you know i
would hang out at video village and
watch this what's up we'll start doing
it ask questions maybe that's what was
so great maybe the fact that you weren't
so aware so aware of yourself that you
could be more free and you could and
almost theatrically in a lot of ways i
never never thought about it i never saw
it as a career i always waited for it i
was always thinking okay this is my last
moment ever
no not like a depressed way i just
thought okay this is fun let's see where
it goes and it just kept going and going
and going is that still how you feel at
this point you finally go ahead no no no
that's my job now that's just uh this is
what how long did it take before you
said okay
i'm an actor because it took me quite a
while before i i thought that oh god
remember when you would fart every time
you could on set yes and everyone loved
it yes yeah remember when you used to
wear sandals and shorts because they
were only shooting you from the waist up
because it was too warm remember when
you had big feet i i
yes talk though
what do you remember
listen anywhere you get your podcasts or
watch on youtube
it does take a long time feel because
you're working with these amazing people
and you're thinking i can't do it yeah
and you think but but you know what
you just have to accept this is what i
do and this is it took me a long time
too many years
i would save god probably even after
breakfast i was still
floundering trying to figure out what
the hell i'm doing really you weren't
sure if you were yeah i wasn't sure but
i think i also i wasn't um
i didn't want to ask anyone i just
assumed they all assumed that i knew
what i was doing
but i didn't have a [ __ ] clue so
you're like why did they keep casting me
why did it keep giving me i don't know
what i'm doing here join tom welling and
michael rosenbaum every week as they
rewind every episode of smallville and
discuss their experiences with friends
fans and co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast